good morning gamers
[Music]
today
today we say goodbye to a dear friend
[Music]
jurgen ii you know the first
jurgen jurgen won at least that was
your fault technically that was your
fault but this
i can't blame on anyone isn't that right
mushroom cow thing
this is all on me isn't that right
sven and claus ikea bird what are you
even doing there
i should not have let jurgen to go
in the mines i didn't even think it was
possible
there's only one thing left to do
let's say goodbye
i can't keep doing this i can't keep
losing the ones i love
that's not right
jurgen deserved better
[Music]
but at least
at least he died happy
look at that history sven is devastated
he refused to leave the boat ikea bird
says the same
i'm all alone one jargon is one jurgen
but two jargons
that's not ryan
i can't even afford a proper burial
come on sven we gotta go pick his
favorite flowers
daisy daisies what's his favorite thing
oh my spent
let us moan
[Music]
we're picking flowers now it's not the
time
leave us alone get him sven
that's right not today
oh my god getting a bit intense here i'm
just trying to pick flowers
she says oh my
god oh
my god you are one tank
you know if there's anyone that's never
gonna never gonna go in spain
i'm just trying to pick flowers
that's literally all i want here we go
this
this is his favorite flowers one day
when i'm rich jurgen i promise
i will get you the full diamond that you
deserve but until then jurgen second
rest easy buddy
[Music]
that's right jurgen one day we'll all
meet together
don't worry but now you are with your
brother
okay i know this is kind of a downer to
start an episode but
the show must go on sven we must
continue our adventure that's what's
that's what jurgen one and two would
have wanted
[Music]
i imagine it oh my god
please not today sven i'm sad too but
something has to be done
sorry how i just hit them one now
ah
[Music]
now i know there's other jurgens out
there but i'm not ready for another
jurgen sven i can't do it
i do remember something from the very
first few episodes there he is
hey buddy me and sven are looking for a
new companion
are you available you're busy you've
literally been here
since episode one what are you doing
here have some wheat
how's that tastes good go away it's not
for you he does like it sven i think he
likes it i think he likes us
tell us donkey son how many times do i
have to do it
please love me i have no one else
please can i ride you
you don't like melon okay well this
might be for the better
listen i got a whole supply back at home
just fall just come with us
my god you eat like a horse i'm
literally out
do i just have to sit on donkey oh okay
we're just chilling
he loves me your name is
all the swedish names are running
through my brain hold up let me get you
a sado let me get you a saddle first
oh my gosh we're under attack not now
for your gun
how dare you
what should i name him i'm really
struggling bernie
is that a good name bernie the beast
you're officially part of the bro gang
he's
so slow
[Laughter]
[Music]
bernie
[Music]
oh god bernie hey bernie there's
there's a couple of people i want you to
meet first of all this is jurgen 2
this is jurgen one this is ikea bird
this is where watersheep used to stay um
hopefully you won't disappear bernie
hopefully you won't
just go places without asking
oh how about that you actually stay
[Laughter]
okay we're gonna gather up for some food
because it's time to seek revenge i
don't know about you guys
but i'm i need to kill something
then you're gonna have to stay hold down
the fort he's trying to make
acquaintances
do i have a name tag can i put an armor
on bernie oh my gosh i never thought of
that
it's a horse armor i doubt i doubt i can
nope what no
just don't die on me bernie please
oh no i know this is a bit
unprecedented there's a
there's a city that i can access
oh my gosh are you kidding me all right
don't be afraid bernie i made it safe
i'll be right after you are you
are you bernie
okay he's fine bernie's fine everyone
welcome to
this is a bad idea okay bernie i forgot
some stuff
just don't go through the portal burning
i need wheat
fast okay i have obsidian
i could get some more where's bernie
there you are okay
let's go bernie we are literally too fat
here we go oh okay
hopefully this should be safe
right god i hope this works
okay so now we're gonna go through at
the same time bernie don't worry
he's fine he's fine the raid has started
it's killing time bernie
for you're again ah kill oh my god why
did i do this at night
kill them back off peasants
how is there so many the youngling stop
running child
that's right bernie no one messes with
us where's the raiders
that's right you're in bernie there they
are
there's no time for emotion stay there
in the name of jurgen i smite thee
where is everyone usually there's a lot
of them
hey iron man where's the raider oh my
gosh
are you okay down there careful not to
fall
here let me give you a hand
[Laughter]
there they are that's right i put a
fence around to stop
raiders imbeciles cowards
hey don't shoot bernie bernie's
sensitive that's what i thought
there's one more remaining
more remaining
could they have spawned like down here
what
you dummy yo shoot if you dare
any last any last word coward
for yaga oh god it continues
eat up bernie the battle continues
oh these are strong careful yeah
oh you're a bum ball of dummy dumb
aren't you
ball of dummy dumb you're all ball of
dummy dumb
hey don't shoot bernie bernie's innocent
bernie three
360 burning noscope
it's apparently 2015. why won't you die
he's taken hostage
no
you're doing great bernie proud of you
these raiders stand no chances oh look
they're rich
where are they attacking from
oh gosh they have the giant horse we
will kill it with bow
oh gosh run buddy
why you will never be jargon
ah run [ __ ] yes
we got your little jurgen fake jurgen
is that a raider it is come at me
coward i gotta say this is a lot easier
than last time
bernie we're too strong hey thanks for
doing nothing by the way
run bernie
ah how i can't do it anymore
you will pay for this
whoa
whoa what is he doing drink
oh gosh oh my gosh he fell down
jesus are you kidding me now
ow i'm out of arrows why can't i just
pull one out of my body
yes oh god don't push me down no
ah i'm scared i'm so scared get the
total number
ah
[Music]
no
this is the worst day of my life
it cannot get any worse than this
this is for jurgen one jurgen to
bernie boat cow
and water sheep oh i only had one
ah
[Applause]
come back coward
add the power of baby in my hands and
thus
the battle is won but we lost burning
but for what cost we lost bernie i can't
celebrate
i can't celebrate without my main man
we're gonna have so many epic adventures
together me and bernie
now i can trade cheaper with the
with the villagers but does it even
matter
you're telling me this guy's charging 26
as discount for a bell
when i can just steal the village bell
[Music]
hi ikea bird bernie didn't make it back
the pay i absolute agony
it shouldn't have been like this and so
you're again
i mean sven oh no we say goodbye to
another hero
[Music]
it's made of dirt well he was poor okay
he was poor
this is what he this is what bernie
would have wanted i knew him since
i was born okay i knew him better than
anyone he loved dirt it's really getting
fooled up in here
[Music]
clearly i don't deserve a horse clearly
i don't even deserve a donkey
there's only one option left to be my
fellow
rider in the night
you're my companions fan not rider it's
different
i know there's someone here come on
where is he there's gotta be at least
one
here he is at last
our last rider in the night that's right
what's your name how do i ride you i
know i can ride
pigs what's your problem do i defeat him
first
did you like that let me write you
oh oh yeah
oh yeah this is what i'm talking about
this is the adventure
that i've been looking for your name is
pee pee poo poo
that's right sven pee pee poo poo we're
gonna beat the ender dragon together
and we're gonna finish the legacy
of legends pee pee poo poo is to live
forever
pee pee poo poo will never die
pee pee poo poo it's my hero you're my
hero pee pee poo poo
that's right who's my pee pee poo would
actually you you're my pee pee poo poo
no
oh my god pee pee poo poo how did you
even do that
pee pee poo poo fine you know what i
understand you don't want to disrespect
mr pee pee poo poo oh now you go back in
pee pee pop oh
how is he's so good at athletics all
right until we build the proper place
for you
you can stay with us you can stay with
us sven spend one at a time please
he can't he's too fat he can't get it my
i god have extra friends pee pee poo poo
there's invaders in our house
wow we killed them pee pee poo poo let's
get him pee pee poo poo
get him pee pee poo poo
[Music]
wow we did it people before we destroyed
the invaders
ah right this way right this way oh my
god
why
stay there sven it's too dangerous more
invaders
kill them
[Music]
you did it we did it we destroyed the
invaders
yeah is it mirror is peeping poopoo
faster
damn people be fast as frick
wait so apparently i can make pee-pee
poo-poo faster
by holding the carrot on the stick
oh my god i'm boosting him faster
pee-pee poo-poo faster
i don't need jurgens i have pee pee poo
poo
okay here's what fake pee pee poo poo
fake pee pee poo poo
okay here's what we're gonna do i lost
too many people
i lost too many loved ones me and a pee
pee poo poo
are just gonna ride in a straight line
and no matter what we're not gonna stop
okay we're going on a pilgrimage
no matter what we're not gonna stop pee
pee poo poo and pewdiepie forever faster
people
all right
follow me pee pee poo poos
we'll write forever in the name of
jurgen a
pilgrimage can never be stopped
we will amass an army an army of peepee
poopoos that will never be stopped
join us in the name of jurgen
only pigs
coward this is like that episode of
forrest gump
oh look it's bernie's girlfriend hello
bernie sorry
sorry about your boyfriend
join us
join us join us fellow peepee poopoo
listen people deal with grief in
different ways
this is how i choose my battle
what is password
[ __ ] what this password
wrong password oh
what this password wrong
password assemble people
all sheep without password permission
has to be destroyed
the password is jurgen smith again
smirgan bergen
targ plargen okay
remember it and don't tell anyone
password you are correct follow us
together we are strong together we are
unstoppable
oh god pee pee poo poos run pee pee pee
poos
ah pee pee poo boys run baby
infinite health people
for year good for yoga foreign
retreat to ikea tower when the time
comes
we will be ready to strike and we are
not afraid
together we are strong i need someone to
dj for me still
hold up i don't know why it's so hard
for me to find dj's
hurry you're coming you're coming back
home with me buddy oh gosh the carpet
ah what is happening jesus now is not
the time
go go go go go go before she sees us how
is he not going through
oh my gosh did i actually okay here we
go
you're our new water cow
which means you have to dj for us i need
to lighten the mood a little bit
yeah that looks good where do i keep the
cd i think this
plays roomy brofist
no he doesn't thank god
where's men
he didn't go through the portal did he
sven you absolute mad lad get uh
i'm trying to end the episode go back no
ben you need to go back
you don't belong in this realm you're
too pure for this world please
my gods man okay gamers
it's been kind it's been a hard episode
it's been a tough one
we met some new friends
and then we lost some new friends but
legends true legends
always lives on as long as we remember
them in our hearts
thanks for watching another episode
smash like and subscribe and get some
jargon merch
[Music]
i'll see you guys tomorrow bye
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price